Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Welcome to The Rest Is History. The horrors of war could not have seemed more remote as my family and I shared our Christmas joy with the growing family of the Commonwealth. Now this madness of war is once more spreading through the world and our brave country must again prepare itself to survive against great odds. Not for a single moment did I imagine that this solemn and awful duty would one day fall
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周独家播客福利、无广告收听、剧集抢先看，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区吗？请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。欢迎收听《历史的余烬》。当我与家人在英联邦日益壮大的大家庭中分享圣诞的欢乐时，战争的恐怖似乎从未如此遥远。而今，战争的疯狂再次在世界各地蔓延，我们英勇的国家必须再次做好准备，在极度艰难的环境中求生。我从未有过哪怕一瞬间的想象，这份庄严而可怕的责任有一天会落到
to me, Dominic Sandbrook. But whatever terrors lie in wait for us all, the qualities that have helped us to keep our freedom intact twice already during this sad century will once more be our strength. The words, slightly adapted, of Queen Elizabeth II on Friday 4th March 1983 as Britain entered the Third World War. Well, there was of course no Third World War in 1983. This was actually a British government exercise, a particularly chilling war game.
我的头上，——多米尼克·桑德布鲁克。但是，无论有什么样的恐怖在等待着我们所有人，曾在这个悲伤的世纪里两次帮助我们完整保持自由的品质，将再次成为我们的力量之源。”这是伊丽莎白二世女王在1983年3月4日星期五，即英国进入第三次世界大战时发表的略作修改的讲话。当然，1983年并没有爆发第三次世界大战。这其实是一场英国政府的演习，一场极其令人不寒栗的军事演习。
But Tom Holland, we both grew up during the 70s and 80s in the kind of heyday of the Cold War and these were kind of chilling times weren't they? Oh they were terrifying whenever you thought about them and I so I grew up outside Salisbury and Salisbury plain obviously big kind of army centre and we were close to the town of Wilton which I think was the some NATO headquarters and I remember must have been late 70s a teacher proudly telling us that Salisbury was third on the Soviet nuclear hit list so apparently he said two nuclear bombs would go off over the North Sea to destroy all the kind of telecommunications or something.
但是，汤姆·霍兰，我们两人都是在70和80年代的冷战全盛期长大的，这些时期有点令人不寒而栗，不是吗？哦，只要你想起来，它们就让人感到恐惧。我是在索尔兹伯里郊外长大的，索尔兹伯里平原显然是一个很大的军队中心，我们离威尔顿镇很近，我想那里是某个北约总部。我记得大约是在70年代末，一位老师自豪地告诉我们，索尔兹伯里在苏联核打击名单上排在第三位。显然他说会有两枚核弹在北海爆炸，以摧毁所有的电信设施之类。
And then the third one was going to be detonated over Beech's bookshop, which was a bookshop. Yeah, it was just outside the close around the cathedral. So Ted Heath would have been in trouble. Ted Heath would have been the first to go um and i remember i remember my father coming to pick us up and sitting in the car and looking out at the spire of salisbury cathedral and imagining you know a sudden flash and the whole of it vanishing and i don't think i ever really recovered no it's a strange thing isn't it because people now i mean younger people will find all this very bizarre but i had exactly we had a teacher at school san i now think of him
然后第三枚将在比奇书店上空引爆，那是一家书店。对，它就在大教堂周围的教堂区外面。所以泰德·希思（Ted Heath）会有麻烦了。泰德·希思会是第一个遭殃的……呃，我记得我父亲来接我们，坐在车里，望着索尔兹伯里大教堂的尖顶，想象着，你知道，一道突然的闪光，整个大教堂就这样消失了，我觉得我从来没有真正恢复过来。不，这真是一件奇怪的事，不是吗？因为现在的人们——我是说年轻人会觉得这一切非常怪异，但我完全有……我们学校有个老师，山姆，我现在想起来他
mr taylor in his socks and sandals he quite clearly was a member of cnd and uh he used to give us sort of little lectures about um the russians had all these missiles aimed at us but we had all these missiles aimed at them and it was really our fault and world war three was you know looming at any moment and um we in the west midlands would be entirely to blame um so but what's it the advantage whenever i get any any kind of millennial grumbling just say that they had easy yeah of course they've got nothing to worry about nothing to worry it's only only global warming or whatever all that stuff yeah that's nothing compared with the threat of mushroom cloud now 1983 um the year we've just been talking about is the subject of a brilliant book about how close the world came to nuclear destruction and we are joined today by the author of said book taylor
泰勒先生穿着袜子配凉鞋，很明显他是核裁军运动（CND）的成员，他过去常常给我们做一些小讲座，关于……俄罗斯人把所有这些导弹对准我们，而我们也把所有这些导弹对准他们，这真的是我们的错，第三次世界大战你知道随时都会迫在眉睫，呃……我们西米德兰兹郡将承担全部责任，所以……但有什么好处呢？每当我听到任何千禧一代发牢骚时，就说他们过得太轻松了，对，当然，他们没什么好担心的，没什么好担心的，只有全球变暖或者诸如此类的东西，所有这些，是的，与蘑菇云的威胁相比，这根本不算什么。现在，1983年——我们刚刚讨论过的那一年——是一本精彩书籍的主题，该书讲述了世界距离核毁灭有多近，今天我们有幸请到了这本书的作者泰勒·唐宁，
downing who also worked what i still think is actually one of the best, one of the absolute best history series ever made. The big sort of, I think, CNN Cold War series in the 1990s, about a thousand parts long, interviews with all the big players. So, Taylor, thank you so much for joining us. And are we right? Is 1983 the moment when the world stood on the brink of destruction, do you think? Well, absolutely it was, yes. I mean, in conventional wisdom, the most dangerous part of the Cold War was the Cuban Missile Crisis, October 1962. That's what most people think of as the most dangerous moment. But certainly I argue in my book, 1983, that in fact it was November 1983, one very specific evening, the evening of the 8th of November 1983, when the
他还制作了我仍然认为是最好的、绝对是史上最棒的历史纪录片系列之一。大约在20世纪90年代，CNN制作的那个庞大的冷战系列，大约有一千集长，采访了所有的大咖。所以，泰勒，非常感谢你加入我们。我们说得对吗？你认为1983年是世界站在毁灭边缘的时刻吗？嗯，完全是的。我的意思是，按照常理，冷战中最危险的部分是1962年10月的古巴导弹危机。大多数人都认为那是极危险的时刻。但我的确在我的书《1983》中争辩说，事实上是1983年11月，一个非常具体的夜晚——1983年11月8日的晚上，当时
world really came closest to nuclear Armageddon. And the big difference between events in the Cuban Missile Crisis and the events in November 1983 is that everybody knew about the Cuban Missile Crisis. The president was addressing the nation, my fellow Americans. There was live television coverage from the Caribbean as ships, Russian ships were intercepted by American warships. Everything was very public. In America, people looked out of their windows and gauged the fastest route to the nearest nuclear air raid shelter. Not that it would have done them much good, but there was a genuine sort of public sense of anxiety in October 1962, whereas in November 1983, nobody knew what was happening. This was behind closed doors completely. And that's why many people say when they discover what was really going on, that actually events in 1983, we knew it was a dangerous year.
世界真正最接近核末日。古巴导弹危机中的事件与1983年11月事件的最大区别在于，每个人都知道古巴导弹危机。总统在向全国发表讲话，“我同胞们，美国人们”。加勒比海地区有电视现场直播，俄罗斯船只被美国军舰拦截。一切都非常公开。在美国，人们看着窗外，估算着离最近的核防空洞的最快路线。倒不是说这会对他们有多大帮助，但在1962年10月，确实有一种真正的公众焦虑感，而在1983年11月，没有人知道发生了什么。这一切完全是在闭门进行的。这就是为什么许多人在发现真相后说，实际上在1983年的事件中，我们知道这是一个危险的年份，
We knew it was a tense time, but actually it was far, far more alarming, far more dangerous than anybody realized at the time. Sorry, Dominic. But I mean, in a way, the implication of this is that, I mean, it's a kind of really frightening one. Because you think that if there is a big global crisis and the eyes of the world are on ships steaming through Caribbean waters or whatever, then we know what we're facing. But actually, at any moment, the world could incinerate. We wouldn't even know about it. Exactly. I mean, that is the terrifying thought from 1983, when the Soviets feared they were coming under attack from the West and prepared a full nuclear strike, a full nuclear retaliation against Western Europe and the United States. And we didn't know about it. And one of
我们知道这是一个紧张的时期，但实际上它比当时任何人意识到的要遥远得多、惊心得多的多，危险得多。对不起，多米尼克。但我的意思是，从某种程度上说，这意味着——我的意思是，这是一种真正令人恐惧的暗示。因为你会想，如果发生了一场巨大的全球危机，全世界的目光都盯着在加勒比海域航行的船只或类似的事情，那么我们就知道我们面临的是什么。但实际上，在任何时刻，世界都可能化为灰烬。我们甚至都不会知道。完全是这样。我的意思是，这就是1983年最令人恐惧的想法，当时苏联人担心他们会遭到西方的攻击，并准备对西欧和美国发动全面的核打击、全面的核报复。而我们却对此一无所知。其中一个
the people I interviewed on the subject was Robert Gates, who was then deputy head of the deputy director of the CIA. And he actually said, he used the phrase, he said, we were on the brink of nuclear war, and we didn't even know it. Now, that's quite something from the deputy head of an intelligence agency. You know, you do want your intelligence operatives to tell you if the other guy's about to biff you on the nose, let alone launch a nuclear strike against you. And this went past almost unnoted in the United States and in Western Europe. So, Taylor, let's talk a bit about the context, because people who haven't studied the Cold War often think of the Cold War as a sort of a great homogenous kind of blob. But obviously, it ebbed and flowed, didn't it, in the early 80s.
我采访过的人是罗伯特·盖茨，他当时是中央情报局副局长。他实际上说过这样的话，他用了这样的短语，他说，我们处于核战争的边缘，而我们甚至都不知道。现在，这话出自一个情报机构的副负责人之口，可谓非同小可。你知道，你确实希望你的情报人员能在别人准备对你鼻子挥拳，更不用说向你发动核打击时告诉你。而这在美国和西欧几乎是在悄无声息中过去的。所以，泰勒，让我们来谈谈背景，因为那些没有研究过冷战的人通常认为冷战是一个巨大的同质化的大团块。但很明显，在80年代初，它是起伏不定的，不是吗？
So we've got to put this into the context of the early 80s. Reagan is president. I think he's talking of the Soviet Union as an evil empire. Andropov is the... So Brezhnev is dead. Andropov is the Soviet leader. And can you... Why do you think there was this sort of new sense of tension,
所以我们必须把这一点放在80年代初的背景下来看。里根是总统。我想他在谈论苏联时称其为一个邪恶帝国。安德罗波夫是……所以勃列日涅夫死了，安德罗波夫是苏联领导人。你能……你认为为什么会有这种新的紧张感，
this sort of... Because there was a real sense of momentum, wasn't there, in 1983, of things spiraling out of control very much so the only way to understand the crisis in november 1983 is as you say dominic to see it in its context um so the 70s had been a period of detente had been a period of when it looked as though east and west were going to get on. There'd been the Helsinki Accords. There'd been the Soyuz space capsule linking up with the Apollo mission in space. What could be more symbolic of unity and friendship than two space capsules linking up in space and so on? But that had all come to an end at the end of the 1970s the soviets
这种……因为在1983年确实有一种真正的势头，局势非常失控，确实如此。要理解1983年11月的危机，正如你所说，多米尼克，唯一的办法就是把它放在它的背景下去看。所以70年代是一个缓和的时期，是一个东西方看起来将要和睦相处的时期。当时签署了《赫尔辛基协定》。还有“联盟号”太空舱在太空中与“阿波罗”任务对接。还有什么比两个太空舱在太空中对接更能象征团结和友谊的呢？诸如此类。但这一切在70年代末走到了尽头。苏联人
had deployed ss20 missiles the americans felt they were being taken for a ride that the soviets were rearming and that led to a shift to the right in the united states which which resulted in the election of ronald reagan whose campaign was very strong on anti-communism was very strong on anti-communism, was very strong that America needed to rearm, needed to face off these guys. We needed to see them down. The bad guys were getting away with it and we mustn't allow them to do this. Now, it's very much part of Reagan's campaign. So when he becomes president in January 1981, he immediately announces and his defence secretary, Caspar Weinberger, in his very first press statement says, we are going to rearm America and a whole new range of stealth bombers and the F-18 and tanks and so on, all of which have been
部署了SS-20导弹，美国人觉得他们被当成冤大头了，苏联人在重新武装，这导致了美国政治向右转，从而选举出了罗纳德·里根，他的竞选口号非常强烈地反对共产主义，非常强烈地反对共产主义，非常强烈地认为美国需要重新武装，需要与这些家伙对抗。我们需要镇压他们。坏人们一直在逃脱惩罚，我们绝不能允许他们这样做。现在，这很大程度上是里根竞选的一部分。因此，当他在1981年1月成为总统时，他立即宣布，他的国防部长卡斯帕·温伯格在最初的新闻发布会上说，我们要重新武装美国，一系列全新的隐形轰炸机、F-18战斗机和坦克等等，所有这些都已经
under development for some years, are all rolled out as quickly as possible. The Navy is increased. Defense expenditure almost doubles in a few years in America to be a huge part of the U.S. gross national product goes into defense spending. And with this, Reagan sort of talks up the anti-communist rhetoric. As you say, he calls theviet union uh an evil empire he announces that they're going to start this fantastic new program strategic defense initiative where they're going to have missiles in space that will intercept incoming missiles star wars isn't it star wars it is instantly named star wars uh and probably won quite a few friends in America by being named after the George Lucas movie. And so the rhetoric is really, really ramping up. And on the other side,
开发了几年，都以最快的速度推出了。海军规模扩大了。美国的国防开支在几年内几乎翻了一番，美国国内生产总值的很大一部分用于国防开支。随之而来的是，里根加强了反共言论。正如你所说，他称苏联呃是一个邪恶帝国，他宣布他们将开始这个宏伟的新计划——战略防御计划，他们将在太空中部署拦截来袭导弹的导弹——那是星球大战，对吧？——星球大战，它立刻被命名为星球大战，而且因为以乔治·卢卡斯的电影命名，可能在美国赢得了不少好感。因此，言论正在真正、真正地升级。而在另一边，
the Soviet Union has stagnated for 20 years under Brezhnev. The economy is hardly advanced. Policies haven't really changed. And when he dies in November 82, the Politburo elect as his successor, not a younger man, not a man with new ideas, not a man with a sort of new vision of the KGB. The KGB is the secret service in the Soviet Union, not only running agents abroad, but also maintaining the surveillance of the entire Soviet society. Every factory has a KGB officer. Every school had KGB officers. Everywhere, the sort of process of watching what people are doing and ensuring nobody steps out of line. The KGB are sort of managing internal security as well as the sort of external stuff that they're probably a bit more famous for now. And this sense of paranoia
苏联在勃列日涅夫的统治下已经停滞了20年。经济几乎没有进展。政策也没有真正的改变。当他在1982年11月去世时，政治局选举他的继承者，不是一个年轻人，不是一个有新思想的人，不是一个对克格勃有某种新愿景的人。克格勃是苏联的秘密警察机构，不仅在国外管理特工，还维持对整个苏联社会的监控。每个工厂都有一个克格勃官员。每个学校都有克格勃官员。到处都是监督人们在做什么以及确保没有人越界的程序。克格勃既管理内部安全，也管理他们现在可能更出名的那种外部事务。而这种偏执感
is building up in Moscow, this terrible sense that the West are economically more advanced, they've got computers. You know, in the Soviet Union in 1983, you couldn't have a typewriter or a photocopier without having an official license from the government. So computers were completely alien. The idea that there should be a free interchange of information and ideas was just completely alien to the centralized soviet system uh and with this comes as i say a sort of sense of paranoia that the west are doing better than we are that they're scheming away in some way that we don't fully understand so when they're when reagan calls the soviet union the evil empire. This is massively offensive.
正在莫斯科积聚，这种可怕的感觉是西方在经济上更先进，他们有电脑。你知道，在1983年的苏联，如果没有政府的官方许可证，你甚至不能拥有一台打字机或复印件。所以电脑对他们来说完全是陌生的。自由交流信息和想法的想法对中央集权的苏联体制来说简直是完全陌生的。随着这一点而来的，正如我所说，是一种偏执狂的感觉，即西方比我们做得更好，他们在以某种我们并不完全理解的方式密谋。所以当里根称苏联为邪恶帝国时，
They're sort of not being given the respect they feel they deserve as a major power. And then when he talks about his Star Wars initiative, they cannot understand whether the Americans have the technology to do this or not. They just feel that it's suddenly going to completely upset the balance. You know, we've been living since the 50s with this concept of mutual assured destruction. We'll probably come back to that later on, I guess. Whereas if either side presses the nuclear button, they know that they're effectively committing suicide, that the retaliation will be so great
这对他们来说是极大的冒犯。他们觉得自己作为大国应有的尊重没有得到。然后，当他谈到他的“星球大战”计划时，他们无法理解美国人是否拥有这样做的技术。他们只是觉得这突然彻底打破了平衡。你知道，从50年代开始，我们就一直生活在“相互保证毁灭”的概念中。我们可能以后会回到这个话题，我猜。而如果任何一方按下核按钮，他们就知道自己实际上是在自杀，因为报复将是如此巨大，
that that'll be the end of the story. And suddenly the Soviets began to think maybe the Americans are getting around this, you know, if they can intercept all our missiles in space, if this Star Wars program can mean we can fire all our missiles, but none of them get through, they have a fantastic advantage over us. The nuclear balance of power or the balance of terror if you like that has prevailed from the 50s onwards is suddenly broken the americans can launch a nuclear war and get away with it because they'll intercept all our missiles and taylor also the the kind of the the close range nuclear missiles that start to be introduced by the americans into britain and
以至于故事就会这样结束。突然间，苏联人开始认为也许美国人正在绕过这一点，你知道，如果他们能在太空中拦截我们所有的导弹，如果这个“星球大战”计划意味着我们可以发射所有导弹，但没有一枚能穿透，他们在我们面前就拥有了巨大的优势。核力量平衡，或者如果你愿意的话，从50年代一直延续至今的恐怖平衡突然被打破了。美国人可以发动核战争而逃脱惩罚，因为他们会拦截我们所有的导弹。泰勒，还有美国人开始在英国和
germany that is also a crucial part of this, is it? It is. Cruise missiles are green and common and so on. Cruise missiles are green and common and the Pershing missiles and so on. Yes, that's very, very, very much part of it. What the Soviets had done in the late 70s was introduce a new range of missiles that were short range. They could attack Western Europe from their bases in the Soviet
德国部署的这种近程核导弹，这也是至关重要的一部分，对吗？是的。巡航导弹是绿色的，常见的等等。巡航导弹是绿色的、常见的，还有潘兴导弹等等。是的，这非常、非常、非常重要。苏联人在70年代末所做的是引入了一系列射程较短的新导弹。他们可以从他们在苏联境内的基地攻击西欧，
Union, the SS-19 and so on, the SS-20, sorry the the this sort of fundamentally shifted the balance that if there were short-range nuclear weapons that could take out parts of europe so america began to roll out its cruise missiles and its um and its pershing missiles and so on and uh that was really the beginnings of a new sort of tit-for-tat regime in the 1980s that was starting to get very, very dangerous. You had this man in the White House talking very aggressively. He called the Soviet Union an evil empire. That's very, very offensive to the Soviets. He was spending billions, almost trillions on rearming America. Everywhere, everything in the American side was computer controlled, whereas the Soviets only had a tiny number of computers in their entire state. This sense that they were sort of losing out, not only to the rhetoric from Reagan, but also to this huge arms expenditure that they couldn't keep up with. And to the sense that, you know, America was winning the Cold War.
SS-19等等，SS-20，抱歉，这从根本上改变了平衡，如果有短程核武器可以消灭欧洲的一部分，那么美国就开始推出其巡航导弹、其……呃……潘兴导弹等等，呃，这确实是20世纪80年代开始变得非常非常危险的新的针锋相对机制的开始。白宫里有这样一个人，说话非常具有侵略性。他称苏联为邪恶帝国。这对苏联人来说是非常非常冒犯的。他在重新武装美国上花费了数十亿、甚至数万亿美元。到处都是，美国方面的一切都是计算机控制的，而苏联整个国家只有少量的计算机。这种感觉不仅是输给了里根的言论，而且还输给了他们无法跟上的巨额军费开支。以及那种，你知道的，美国正在赢得冷战的感觉。
But what's so fascinating about that, Taylor, I think is, I mean, H.A.B. Taylor, I think it was, who said that, you know, wars are generally are generally start not because people are kind of aggressive, but because they're afraid. And one thing that nobody in the West ever seemed to really get, and certainly this came as a great shock to Reagan, and we'll come to this later, I suspect, was that the Russians were scared of them. Because they thought of the Russians as these sort of malevolent Bond villain-type sort of conspirators sitting around their giant... I remember this great scene in Octopussy, a Bond film of 1983, where they're all sitting around this huge table and they've got maps and it's all very high-tech.
但最迷人的是，泰勒，我认为，我是说H.A.B.泰勒，我想是他说的，你知道，战争通常爆发不是因为人们好斗，而是因为他们害怕。西方似乎从来没有人真正理解的一件事——这肯定给里根带来了巨大的震惊，我们稍后会讨论这一点，我猜——那就是俄罗斯人害怕他们。因为他们把俄罗斯人想象成那些坐在巨型……我记得1983年邦德电影《八爪女》中那个伟大的场景，他们都坐在一张巨大的桌子旁，有地图，而且都非常高科技。
And what the people in the West didn't get was that the people in the Kremlin were actually frightened, that they thought the West would strike first. But also, the people in the West are frightened, right? Yeah, of course, because know the soviet union has invaded afghanistan and it's crushing yeah trade unions in poland and everything i get all that i'm not i'm not i'm not sort of saying the soviet union so this is a very anecdote very anecdotal and i'm not sure how much credence to place on it but i was just out having a coffee before that we recorded this podcast and
而西方人没有理解的是，克里姆林宫的人实际上是害怕的，他们认为西方会率先发动打击。但是，西方的人也很害怕，对吧？是的，当然，因为你知道苏联已经入侵了阿富汗，并且正在镇压……是的，波兰的工会等等，我明白这一切，我不是，我不是，我不是在说苏联……这是一个非常个人的轶事，我不知道该相信多少，但在我们录制这个播客之前，我刚刚出去喝了杯咖啡，
i mentioned to this guy who was sitting next to me what the theme of the podcast was going to be was he a stranger he was he well he i i can't reveal his identity because um he he said that that's very cool he had he had knowledge of of the workings of the cabinet um in uh in 1983 and said that a leading cabinet officer uh a leading member of the cabinet um in uh in 1983 and said that a leading cabinet officer uh a leading member of the cabinet had um commissioned the building of a nuclear bunker really a private one for himself and i said can i quote you on that and he said uh not by name there was a trade in nuclear bunkers in the i mean there was an ideal bunker exhibition yes and and the advice was that you get your bunker but also you have to invest in a gun.
我向坐在我旁边的那个人提到了这个播客的主题将是什么，他是陌生人吗？他……我不能透露他的身份，因为……呃……他说这很酷，他了解1983年内阁的工作情况，并说1983年的一位内阁高级官员、内阁高级成员……呃……1983年的一位内阁高级官员……内阁高级成员……呃……委托建造了一个核掩体，真的，是他自己的私人掩体。我说我能引用你的话吗？他说，呃，不能用名字。当时的核掩体交易……我的意思是，甚至还有一个理想的掩体展览，是的，建议是你要有一个掩体，但你也必须投资一把枪。
You already have, because you've got to kill your neighbours. You've got to kill your neighbours. Anyway, sorry, Taylor. Anyway, let's get back. But essentially, there's a climate of fear on both sides, right? Climate of fear on both sides, yes, absolutely. But I think you're right in saying that whilst America was, particularly under Reagan, was sort of aggressive and was
你已经有了，因为你得杀掉你的邻居。你必须杀掉你的邻居。总之，抱歉，泰勒。总之，让我们回到正题。但本质上，双方都存在恐惧的气候，对吧？双方都存在恐惧的气候，是的，绝对是。但我认为你说得对，虽然美国，特别是在里根的领导下，有点好斗，而且
punching out and this constant rhetoric against the Soviet Union, the Soviets were feeling that they were falling behind, that their technology wasn't quite as good as that of the West. They didn't understand how things worked in the West and that they were falling behind in this race. Therefore, they needed to be sort of extra careful, extra watchful, extra vigilant against what the Americans were up to. And suddenly this sort of new figure, this old Hollywood star, you know, appears on the stage and attacks them almost sort of day after day. The rhetoric is building up and it scared them. It absolutely scared them. So they started a process, it was called Operation Rian, which was to look out for indicators that the Americans were preparing to launch a nuclear attack.
不断出击，并对苏联进行持续的言论攻击，但苏联人觉得他们落后了，他们的技术不如西方那么好。他们不理解西方是如何运作的，他们在这场竞赛中落后了。因此，他们需要对美国人在搞什么鬼保持格外的小心、格外的注视、格外的警惕。突然间，这个新人物、这个老好莱坞明星，你知道，出现在舞台上，几乎是日复一日地攻击他们。言论不断升级，这吓坏了他们。这绝对吓坏了他们。所以他们开始了一个名为“雷亚恩行动”（Operation Rian）的行动，旨在寻找美国正准备发动核打击的迹象。
And some of these were pretty sort of sensible. You know, are the military mobilising? Well, obviously that would happen if there was going to be a nuclear attack. So their agents were told to go and look for mobilisation of the military. Were blood banks being stored up in case the casualty rate increased? You know, sensible things like that. But eventually it became completely absurd. So agents were told to go and count the lights that were on in the Pentagon in Washington or the Ministry of Defence in London at night.
其中一些相当明智。你知道，军方在动员吗？嗯，如果有核打击的话，显然会发生这种事。所以他们的特工被告知去寻找军方动员的迹象。是否在储存血库以防伤亡人数增加？你知道，诸如此类明智的事情。但最终它变得完全荒谬了。因此，特工们被告知去数一数晚上华盛顿五角大楼或伦敦国防部亮着的灯的数量。
And if they were more than a certain number, this would clearly conclude that they were sort of plotting away at night. And if they came up with these marks, then they'd get promotion. So there was a kind of incentive. Exactly, yes. The whole process fed on itself. The agents in the field, even if they, know living in london or washington thought well obviously america is not prepared britain's not preparing to go to war but you don't you got no promotion for saying that
如果它们超过了一定数量，这显然可以得出结论，他们在夜里密谋。如果他们想出了这些迹象，他们就会得到晋升。所以有一种激励机制。完全正确，是的。整个过程自食其果。身处前线的特工们，即使他们，你知道，住在伦敦或华盛顿，心想，显然美国没有准备好，英国也没有准备好开战，但你不会因为这么说而得到晋升。
you only got promotion for finding the evidence that yes look look that they're planning something so when there's a a perfectly neutral announcement on on the bbc that there's a new call for blood donors um through the national health service that's reported back to moscow look they're preparing for war because they're gathering blood banks you see so one thing after another sort of feeds itself and this rather frenzied paranoid paranoid view in Moscow. And then there's this war game, this NATO war game. Well, yes, the war game comes at the end of a very, very tense year. 1983 had sort of built up stage by stage. You can only really understand the events in November 1983 by sort of seeing it in the context of what I think we now look back
你只有找到证据证明“看，看，他们在策划什么”才能获得晋升。所以当BBC播出一个完全中立的公告，称国家医疗服务体系（NHS）正在呼吁新的献血者时，这被汇报回了莫斯科：看，他们在准备战争，因为他们在收集血库，你看。所以一件事接着一件事地自我滋养，形成了莫斯科这种狂热的、偏执的观点。然后就有了这场军事演习，这场北约的军事演习。嗯，是的，这场军事演习发生在一个非常、非常紧张的一年的末尾。1983年是一步步积累起来的。你只有把1983年11月的事件放在我们现在回看所处的背景下，才能真正理解它们，
on is probably probably the most dangerous year certainly up with 1962 and the Cuban Missile Crisis anyway certainly one of the most dangerous years um in in the Cold War and there were you know there were a series of events that sort of um jacked up the the the the danger as far as the Soviets were concerned. So there's the rhetoric coming from the White House, coming from the president himself, coming from Reagan, the evil empire speech, and so on. Then there are a series of war games that the Americans play that constantly rattle the Soviet defences.
这可能是最危险的一年，当然不亚于1962年和古巴导弹危机，无论如何，绝对是冷战中最危险的年份之一，并且有一系列事件，呃，在苏联人看来，加剧了危险。因此，来自白宫的言论，来自总统本人的言论，来自里根的言论，邪恶帝国演讲等等。然后是一系列美国人进行的、不断震撼苏联防御的军事演习。
You know, they'll fly jets right up to the edge of the soviet board and then sort of veer away at the last possible second that's top gun that's top gun stuff but you see what they're doing they've got they've got these giant kc-135 uh um listening aircraft up recording all the all the chat and all the dialogue on the Soviet system. This is going on constantly through 1983. Then there's this remarkable event at the end of August 1983, when a civilian airline, a Korean airline, a flight Cal 007, veers hundreds of miles off course over some of the most sensitive territory in the Soviet Union, the Kamchatka Peninsula, and then over Sakhalin Island and towards the mainland. It's still not really very clear quite
你知道，他们会把喷气式飞机一直开到苏联边界的边缘，然后在最后一秒钟转向离开——那是壮志凌云，那是壮志凌云的把戏——但你看到他们在做什么了，他们有这些巨型的KC-135监听飞机在空中记录苏联系统上的所有聊天和所有对话。这种情况在整个1983年一直在发生。然后是1983年8月底发生的一件非同寻常的事，当时一架民航客机，一架韩国航空公司的客机，KAL 007航班，在飞越苏联一些最敏感的领土——堪察加半岛，然后飞越萨哈林岛并朝中国大陆方向——时，偏离航线数百英里。目前仍不是很清楚这架客机是如何偏离航线这么远的，但在某个时刻，它与一架正在进行电子信息搜集的美国侦察机重叠、擦肩而过。苏联系统显然在某种程度上对这究竟是一架民航客机还是一架美国间谍任务产生混淆，于是他们将其击落。这架韩国客机上269名完全无辜的人丧生。当然，美国的言论，愤怒，那种怎么会有任何系统，你知道，击落一架民航客机，无法区分军用飞机和民航客机，将其击落，杀死所有这些无辜的人，你知道，愤怒在那个时候绝对爆发了，
how this airliner managed to get so off course, But at one point, it overlaps, it passes an American reconnaissance plane, which is out electronically gathering information. And the Soviet system clearly in some way gets confused as to whether this is a civilian airliner or is an American spy mission. And they shoot it down. 269 completely innocent people on this Korean airliner are killed. And of course, the American rhetoric, the outrage, the sense of how can any system, you know, shoot down a civilian airliner, not be able to distinguish between a military plane and an airliner shoot it down kill all these innocent people you know the outrage absolutely um erupts at that point uh and the
里根称苏联为一个恐怖主义国家，你知道，这真的是非常严厉的东西。还有另外几起事件发生，实际上与冷战完全无关。1983年10月底，真主党用一枚巨大的卡车炸弹炸毁了贝鲁特的一个美国海军陆战队基地。美国人作为以色列和巴勒斯坦战争后的维和人员驻扎在那里。美国将其在世界各地的所有基地置于警戒状态，以防范恐怖分子。
reagan calls the soviet union a terrorist state you know this is this is really sort of severe stuff and there's a couple of other incidents that happen, totally unconnected effectively with the Cold War. To the end of October 1983, the Hezbollah blow up an American Marine base in Beirut with a huge truck bomb. The Americans are there as peacekeepers after the war between Israel and the Palestinians. And America puts all its bases around the world on alert to look out for terrorists.
苏联人察觉到了这一点，但认为这是因为他们准备发动核攻击。然后美国人入侵了加勒比海的小岛格林纳达并接管了该岛。那是英联邦领土的一部分。因此撒切尔和里根之间发生了巨大的争吵。伦敦和华盛顿之间有大量的通信。这是苏联人一直在寻找的另一个迹象。如果他们准备发动攻击，
The Soviets pick this up, but think this is because they're preparing to launch a nuclear attack. Then there's the Americans invade the tiny Caribbean island of Grenada and take over the island. And that's part of the Commonwealth territory. So there's a huge row of bills between Thatcher and Reagan. And there's massive communication between London and Washington. That's another sign that the Soviets are looking out for. If they're about to launch an attack,
伦敦和华盛顿将保持定期联系。所以一个接一个，苏联人捕捉到了这些迹象，它们与冷战完全无关，但它们似乎在打勾。你知道，在卢比扬卡，克格勃的负责人，他们有一面墙，据说他们有一面——我听说他们有一面有机玻璃墙，一边是矩阵，上面是国家，每当发生事件时，
London and Washington will be in regular contact. So one by one, these sort of signs are picked up in the Soviet Union, completely separate to anything to do with the Cold War, but they seem to be sort of ticking boxes. You know, in the Lubyanka the head of the the kgb they have a they have a wall they apparently had i've been told they had a sort of perspex wall with sort of matrix down one side and countries across and every time an incident
他们就会在这面有机玻璃墙上打个叉，字面意思就是人们可以走过去——这非常高科技，不是吗？——是的，人们可以走进去，看到这些叉子不断累积，在卢比扬卡、在克格勃总部的大黑板上，叉子一个接一个地增多。然后事件发生了，它差点引发了冲突，这是一场北约演习，这是一场年度演习，名为“优秀射手”（Able Archer）。所以这就是“优秀射手”。在这场演习中，北约——这不是那种军队走出去到处移动的演习。它被称为指挥所演习。这是一场通信演习，他们在其中虚构了一个场景：发生了一场常规战争，北约正开始战败。华沙条约组织、苏联和东欧国家之间对西欧发动了常规战争。
occurred they sort of put a cross on on this perspex wall and literally people could walk it very high tech isn't it yeah people can walk in bingo card and walk in and look and see these sort of crosses building up and one by one there are more crosses on the big board in the in the lubyanka in the kgb headquarters and then then the incident comes which nearly sparks it off and this is a nato exercise it's an annual exercise called able archer so this is able archer. And in this exercise, the NATO, it's not an exercise where troops go out and move all around. It's called a command post exercise. It's a communications exercise in which they invent a scenario in which there's a conventional
看起来北约要输了。因此，向军事人员提出了请求，要求平民做出回应，请求使用核武器进行反击。就在这时，苏联人想，这不是军事演习。这不是演练。这已经变成了真的。西方、北约即将对苏联发动核武器。所以他们准备了他们全部的核武库。巨大的SS-19百吨级导弹进入最高戒备状态。潜艇部署在北极冰层下，准备向西方发射导弹。
war, which NATO are beginning to lose. A conventional war between the Warsaw Pact, the Soviet and the Eastern Bloc countries attack Western Europe. And it looks as though NATO is losing. So there's a request to the military people put into the civilians, a request to use nuclear weapons to respond. And at this point, the Soviets think, this is no war game. This is no practice. This has now become the real thing. The West, NATO is about to launch nuclear weapons against the Soviet Union. So they prepare their full nuclear arsenal. Giant SS-19 100-ton missiles are put on maximum alert. Submarines are deployed under the Arctic ice, ready to fire their missiles
机动式SS-20被派往苏联的森林和沼泽中，准备发射它们的导弹。在1983年11月8日的夜晚，安德罗波夫——此时他是一个重病缠身的人，他甚至不在克姆林宫，而是在莫斯科郊外的一个诊所里——那个携带着被称为“切格特”（Cheget）的核扳机的人（他们在苏联被称为“切格特”，相当于美国的“核足球”），带着密码的人出来坐在他旁边，等待着下达发射指令，对西方发动这规模宏大的核报复。夜晚一点点过去，
against the West. The mobile SS-20s are sent out into the forests and the swamps of the Soviet Union, ready to fire their missiles. And on the night of the 8th of November, 1983, Andropov, who's a very ill man at this point he's not even in the Kremlin he's in a clinic outside Moscow the guy with the nuclear trigger called Cheget they were called Cheget in the Soviet Union it's the equivalent to the nuclear football
早上演习结束了，没有发生袭击。那里有一点紧张感，汤姆，我想你做到了。我们都被消灭了吗？但那是《德国83年》的背景，对吧？是的，那种精彩的德国电视剧，关于——是的，一个间谍在——不是具体指“优秀射手”，但那个极其危险的1983年的总体紧张局势确实是背景，是的。泰勒，那天晚上安德罗波夫需要什么才会说“发射”？换句话说，是一起边界冲突吗？我的意思是，这种事经常发生，对吧？我的意思是，难道只需要一件小事就能让他说“好吧，干吧”吗？我想会的，多米尼克。我认为当危机升级到那个水平时，接管的不再是理性考量。任何微小的误解，对正在发生的事情的任何微小的错误解释。你知道，柏林的一个事件可能就是下达“好吧，发射那些导弹”的最终导火索。
the guy with the codes sort of comes out and sits up with him waiting to give the go-go to launch this massive nuclear retaliation against the west and the night ticks on ticks through and uh in the morning the war game comes to an end and there is no attack there was a bit of tension there tom i think you did it happen did we all get destroyed but that's the background to um deutschland 83 isn't it yes that kind of wonderful german drama about it is yes that's
好吧，如果他们这样做了，会发生什么？那么西方有多少城市、多少基地、多少会被摧毁？嗯，我们不知道苏联核武库的确切细节。所有这些事情在当时显然都是最高机密，现在仍然笼罩在秘密之中。但会有类似这样的情况，他们拥有大约11,000枚核弹头，可能更多，但我们知道他们肯定有11,000枚。它们的目标是——嗯，显然它们的目标是索尔兹伯里，正如我们之前听到的那样。
a spy in the not specifically abel archer but but the general tension in that very dangerous year of 1983 is the background yes to that Taylor what would it have taken that night for Andropov to have said go? So in other words, a border incident? I mean, those things happened all the time, right? I mean, could it just have taken one small thing for him to say, yeah, go for it? I think it could, Dominic. I think when crises escalate to that level, it's not really rational consideration that takes over. Any slight misunderstanding, any slight misinterpretation of what's going on. You know, an incident in Berlin could just have been the final trigger to say, right, fire those missiles.
是的，比蒂的书店会……是的，是的，那家书店会在第一波攻击中。所以有很多目标，主要是军事目标，一些平民目标。有些导弹不够精确，无法击中精确的目标。所以其中一些不会以机场或导弹井为目标。其中一些会以城市为目标。当然，一旦这些导弹发射，它们就会被美国探测到。
OK, so if they did, what would have happened? So how many cities in the West, how many bases, how many would have been taken out? Well, we don't know the exact details of the Soviet nuclear arsenal. All these things were obviously very top secret at the time and are still shrouded in secrecy. But there would have been something like, they had something like 11,000 nuclear warheads, probably a lot more, but we know they certainly had 11. They were targeted on, well, obviously they were targeted on Salisbury, as we heard earlier.
是的，我认为毫无疑问。尽管——因为我一直在想的是，他们当时知道核冬天的概念吗？是的。是的，每个人都知道这一点。每个人都知道这一点，汤姆。所以本质上，无论发生什么你都会死。我的意思是，它不……是的，这就是为什么它被称为“相互保证毁灭”，
Yeah, Beatty's bookshop would have... Yeah, yeah, that bookshop would have been in the first wave. So there were a multitude of targets, military targets mostly, some civilian targets. Some of the missiles weren't accurate enough to hit a sort of precise target. So some of them wouldn't have been targeted on airfields or missile silos. Some of them would have been targeted on cities. And, of course, as soon as those missiles had been launched, they would have been picked up in the United States.
因为众所周知，如果一方攻击另一方，报复将摧毁另一方。我的意思是，将会发生的是西欧的大部分、北美的大部分将在第一波攻击中被消灭。然后在报复中，东欧的大部分和亚洲的大部分将被消灭。但随后，正如你所说，汤姆，核冬天就会降临。以至于甚至那些国家，你知道的，第三世界国家，
Yes, I think without any question. Even though, because I guess what I'm wondering is, did they know about nuclear winters at this point? Yes. Yeah, everyone knew about that. Everyone knew about that, Tom. So essentially, you're going to die whatever happens. I mean, it doesn't... Yes, that's why it's called mutual assured destruction
甚至，你知道的，南部非洲最终也会被吞没。新西兰和澳大利亚，内维尔·舒特（Neville Shute）的书里不是写过吗？没错，是的，是的，稍微倒回一点。所以苏联显然有一种西方会首先打击的感觉，但这种感觉并不是不合理的，
because it's known that if one side attacks the other, the retaliation will destroy the other side. I mean, what would have happened is much of Western Europe, much of North America would have been taken out in the first wave. Then in the retaliation, much of Eastern Europe and much of Asia would have been taken out. But then this nuclear winter, as you say, Tom, would have descended. So that even countries, you know, third world countries,
因为我经历过——你知道的，他们管它们叫什么，Wintec Symex，英国政府的军事演习，比如1981年的那次——这种感觉并不是不合理的，因为我经历过——你知道的，他们管它们叫什么，Wintec Symex，英国政府的军事演习，比如1981年的那次——极其详细，你可以在线看到很多解密的档案。所以这些军事演习经常设想，如果发生战争，苏联或华约的常规部队对北约来说将过于强大，然后最终——所以Wintec Symex 81演习以北约指挥官要求华盛顿和伦敦批准在战场上使用核武器而告终，
even, you know, Southern Africa would have eventually been engulfed New Zealand and Australia, the Neville Shute book isn't there? That's right yes, yeah, yeah to go back a little bit so the Soviet Union obviously had a sense that the West would strike first but that wasn't an unreasonable sense
其计划是——你可以在网上看到精彩的记录，我想——内阁讨论的精彩会议记录，他们基本上说，嗯，我们不会消灭苏联。我们消灭一些东欧卫星国来展示我们有限的，你知道的，因为那样他们可能不会压倒性地做出反应。所以如果我们只核平罗马尼亚和波兰，那么也许，你知道的，索尔兹伯里就会安全。苏联会认识到我们有限的目标。苏联会消灭伯明翰，不是吗？
because I've been through the you know, what do they call them, Wintec Symex the British government war games and the one in 1981 for example sense because i've been through the you know they they what they call them wintek cymex the um the british government war games and the one in 1981 for example incredibly detailed that you can see a lot of online declassified files so these war games often envisaged that in the event of war the soviet or warsaw pack conventional forces would be would be too strong for nato and then eventually so the wintec cymex 81 exercise ends with the nato commanders asking um washington and london for permission to use nuclear weapons in the field and the plan is and there's a brilliant you can read it online i think
在第三次世界大战中，哈克特将军（General Hackett），是的，这正是发生的事情，那是明斯克和伯明翰，我想是明斯克和伯明翰。但我的意思是，这种认为会是苏联首先使用核武器的想法——我的意思是，苏联在某种程度上不需要这样做，因为他们在欧洲的常规武器、常规部队是如此强大，我说的对吗，泰勒？是的，绝对是的。我的意思是，他们在远远超出西方常规部队所能及的范围内，拥有200个陆军师。但这就是“优秀射手”，北约的演习，它的意义所在。它关乎一场常规对抗中的失败，因此要求使用核武器，而这
there's the brilliant minutes of the cabinet discussion where they basically say well we won't take out the soviet union We take out some of the Eastern European satellites to show our limited, you know, because then maybe they won't respond overwhelmingly. So if we just nuke Romania and Poland, then maybe, you know, Salisbury will be safe. The Soviet Union will recognise our limited aims. The Soviet Union will take out Birmingham, isn't that right?
内阁讨论的会议纪要非常精彩，他们基本上说，好吧，我们不攻击苏联，我们攻击一些东欧卫星国来展示我们的局限性，你知道，因为这样他们也许就不会作出过度的反应。所以如果我们只是对罗马尼亚和波兰使用核武器，那么也许，你知道，索尔兹伯里就会安全。苏联会承认我们的有限目标。苏联会摧毁伯明翰，对吧？
In World War III the general Hackett yeah that is that's exactly what happens it's Minsk and Birmingham I think Minsk and Birmingham but I mean this idea that it would have been the Soviet Union that would have used nuclear weapons first I mean the Soviet in a way they didn't need to because their conventional weapon their conventional forces in Europe were so strong am I right Taylor yeah yes absolutely yes I mean they have 200 army divisions, you know, available in way beyond anything that the Western conventional forces have. But that's what Abel Archer, the NATO exercise, that's what it was about. It was about a defeat in a conventional confrontation, and therefore the request to use to use nuclear weapons and that
在第三次世界大战中，哈克特将军，是的，这正是发生的事情，那是明斯克和伯明翰，我认为是明斯克和伯明翰，但我的意思是，这种认为会是苏联首先使用核武器的想法，我的意思是，苏联在某种程度上不需要这样做，因为他们在欧洲的常规武器、常规部队太强大了，我说得对吗，泰勒？是的，绝对是的，我的意思是他们有200个陆军师，你知道，其规模远远超过西方常规部队所能拥有的任何东西。但这就是“优秀射手”（Able Archer）北约演习的内容，这就是它的意义所在。它是关于在常规对抗中的失败，因此要求使用、使用核武器，并且...
was what the soviets you see the soviets had always planned in their attacks upon the west they'd always planned to do it in the guise of a of a military war game so that the west wouldn't wouldn't realize that that was so they assume that the west are going to do exactly the same it's going to be a military war game that isn't in fact a war game. It's the real thing. They assume this is all maskrovka. They called it in Russian deception.
你知道，苏联人对西方的攻击一直都有这样的计划：他们总是计划以军事战争游戏的伪装来实施，这样西方就不会意识到这就是现实，所以他们假定西方也会做完全一样的事情——这会是一场其实并非战争游戏的军事战争游戏，而是来真的。他们假设这一切都是“马斯夫罗卡”，他们在俄语中把这叫做欺骗。
Every signal in the Able Archer war game, and there were signals being sent around sort of pretending all these things were happening, began with the words exercise, exercise, exercise, and then the signals. But of course, in the Soviet mindset, well, that's exactly what they would say, wouldn't they? They're not going to pretend this is the real thing. They're going to pretend it's a war game, and then they're going to attack us. I think we should take a break, Tom. This is so unbelievably fascinating. I think we should take a break. But kind of terrifying. We should talk a
“神射手”军事演习中的每一个信号——而且当时发送的各种信号都在假装所有这些事情正在发生——都是以“演习、演习、演习”这几个词开头，然后才是信号内容。但当然，在苏联的思维模式里，嗯，他们当然会这么说，不是吗？他们才不会假装这是真的呢。他们会假装这是一场军事演习，然后就会对我们发动进攻。我想我们应该休息一下，汤姆。这实在是令人难以置信的入迷。我想我们该休息一下了。但也有点吓人。我们应该稍微谈谈
tiny bit about the reaction to the Abel Arch thing, so Reagan completely changing his mindset, which is an extraordinary story and still not, I think, as well-known as it should be. And then we'll talk more generally about nuclear weapons. So we'll see you after the nuclear winter of the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews,
大家对“神射手”事件的反应，也就是里根完全改变了他的思维方式，这是一个非凡的故事，而且我认为它至今仍没有得到应有的广泛了解。然后我们会更广泛地讨论核武器。所以我们在核严冬般的广告休息之后再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐其余》。这是你获取娱乐新闻、评论的每周必看节目，
splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
还有各种娱乐圈八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们会揭开娱乐界的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家播客以及提前购买现场演出门票的权限，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。
Hello, welcome back. We are on the cheery topic of how close the world came to total nuclear destruction. And on that theme, if you're interested in it and i i i don't really see how you couldn't be um i do recommend another podcast series um atomic hobo presented by julie mcdowell which whenever i want to make my flesh creep i listen to it and it's it's terrifying and brilliant and i can't recommend it highly enough anyway but enough about Julie's podcast let's get back to ours um we have uh Taylor Downing with us who has been talking about 1983 um Able Archer the world at the brink um but Taylor this is this is exists in the context obviously of the entire post-war period and I guess it the story begins with Hiroshima and Nagasaki when the eyes of the world and I guess particularly the Soviet Union is open to the fact that the United States have a
你好，欢迎回来。我们现在要讨论一个令人高兴的话题：世界距离彻底的核毁灭曾经有多近。顺便说一句，如果你对这个主题感兴趣——而且我真的不明白你怎么会不感兴趣——嗯，我向大家推荐另一个播客系列《原子流浪汉》（Atomic Hobo），由朱莉·麦克道尔（Julie McDowell）主持。每当我想起鸡皮疙瘩直起时，我就会听它，它既可怕又精彩，我极力向大家推荐。好了，关于朱莉的播客就说到这里，让我们回到我们自己的节目上来。我们请来了泰勒·唐宁（Taylor Downing），他一直在谈论1983年、“神射手”演习以及处于边缘的世界。但是，泰勒，这一切显然都存在于整个战后时期的背景之下，我想这个故事始于广岛和长崎，当时世界的目光，尤其是苏联，清醒地认识到美国拥有
devastating weapon that gives them an overwhelming military advantage for as long as the Soviet Union doesn't have these weapons? Yes, absolutely. 70,000 killed within a few months in Hiroshima and probably well over 100,000 from the nuclear fallout that followed. And then another bomb, a different type of bomb in Nagasaki a few days later, finishes the Second World War and really is the dawn of the next conflict, the Cold War that follows. It's quite soon that the Soviets catch up. They have their spies at Los Alamos, where the Americans had produced the atomic bomb. And in 1949, I think it was August 1949, the Soviets detonate their first atomic bomb. And so the sort of balance of power
一种毁灭性的武器，只要苏联没有这种武器，就能给美国带来压倒性的军事优势？是的，完全如此。广岛在几个月内就有7万人丧生，随后的核沉降物造成的死亡人数可能远超10万人。几天后，长崎又挨了另一颗不同类型的炸弹，这结束了第二次世界大战，也确实拉开了下一场冲突——随后的冷战的序幕。苏联人很快就追上来了。他们在洛斯阿拉莫斯拥有间谍，美国人正是在那里制造了原子弹。在1949年，我想那是1949年8月，苏联人引爆了他们的第一颗原子弹。因此，这种力量平衡
then effectively becomes a balance of terror. The two superpowers in the world, the United States leading the Western democratic world, the Soviet Union leading the communist bloc, both have atomic weapons, and can sort of stare at each other, you know, across the divide. And there are several, several incidents, as we know, that sort of... But before that, before that, while the Americans have the monopoly, is there any talk about, you know, let's launch a preemptive strike, let's take them
随后实际上演变成了恐怖平衡。世界上的两个超级大国——领导西方民主世界的美国，以及领导共产主义阵营的苏联——都拥有原子武器，并且可以在分界线两侧互相瞪眼。正如我们所知，有多次、多次事件……但在那之前，在美方拥有垄断地位的时候，有没有人讨论过，比如说，让我们发起先发制人的打击，趁我们还能做到的时候把他们消灭掉？不，没有。苏联曾是美国的盟友。他们对苏联针对柏林的行动作风感到非常恼火，并以柏林空运作出回应。他们推出了马歇尔计划，以在二战的毁灭之后支撑欧洲经济。但没有，我认为当时没有任何人讨论过“啊，我们要悄悄溜过去”。我的意思是，可能有一两个非常浮夸、极好战的军事人物说过，“现在是时候了，让我们把这些家伙炸回石器时代去吧”。我们知道在20世纪50年代，战略空军司令部的柯蒂斯·李梅（Curtis LeMay）、托马斯·鲍尔斯（Thomas Power）之流确实说过这样的话。但我认为当时在最高层并没有任何
out while we can? No, no. The Soviet Union had been America's ally. They were very irritated by Soviet behaviour towards Berlin and responded with a Berlin airlift. They responded with a Marshall Plan to sort of shore up the European economies after the devastation of the Second World War. But no, I don't think there was any talk that, ah, we'll sneak away. I mean, there might have been one or two very bombastic, very combative military figures who said, now's the time, you know, let's blow these guys back into the Stone Age. We know that was said a few times in the 1950s by the Kurt LeMay's and the Thomas Powers and these sort of people who ran strategic air command. But I don't think there was any
严肃的考虑，要利用这种优势来对付苏联。美国只是希望——美国希望它能保持对核武器的垄断。而且我认为CIA曾估计，要等到50年代末苏联人才能赶上。所以当他们在1949年引爆第一颗原子弹时，这是一个巨大的惊吓。但随后整个事情进入了一个新时代，进入了氢弹和热核武器的时代。因此，投在广岛的那颗炸弹，用技术术语来说，是一颗1.4万千吨的炸弹。这大致相当于14,000吨TNT当量。巨大，绝对是庞然大物。但在整个50年代，随着双方开始测试氢弹的使用，这种规模呈几何级数上升。我们现在谈论的是百万吨级，即数百万吨TNT当量，
serious thinking at the top level about using this advantage against the Soviet Union. They simply hoped, America hoped that it would maintain its monopoly of nuclear weapons. And I think the CIA had estimated that it would probably be the end of the 50s before the Soviets catch up. So it's a great surprise when in 1949, they detonate their first atomic bomb. But then the whole thing goes into a new era, into hydrogen, into thermonuclear weapons. So the bomb that had been dropped on Hiroshima, in technical terms, was a bomb of 14,000 kilotons. That's roughly equivalent to 14,000 tons of TNT. Huge, absolutely massive. But through the 50s, as both sides start testing the use of hydrogen bombs, this escalates off the scale. We're now talking about megatons, millions of tons of TNT equivalent,
其爆炸威力相当于数百万吨TNT。因此，美国发射并引爆了一枚10百万吨（1000万吨）的导弹。苏联则以一枚20百万吨的导弹回应。最后，在1961年，苏联引爆了有史以来最大的炸弹，高达50百万吨，即5000万吨TNT当量。记住，广岛那颗是14,000吨，而我们知道那已经具有极具毁灭性的威力了。所以人们只能开始想象，一枚50百万吨的炸弹爆炸会是什么样子，而美国人也做出了同样的反应。某些研究这一切的美国思想家开始谈论“百万人死亡”（mega deaths），他们用数百万人的死亡来衡量伤亡。这一切都变得彻头彻尾地可怕，武器的规模
the explosive power equivalent to millions of tons of TNT. So the Americans launch a detonated missile of 10 megatons, 10 million tons. The Soviets respond with one of 20 megatons. And finally, in 1961, the largest bomb ever detonated by the Soviet Union is of 50 megatons, 50 million tons of TNT. Remember, Hiroshima was 14,000, and we know how massively destructive that was. So one can only begin to imagine what an explosion of a 50 megaton and americans respond the same way and certain american thinkers who are working on all this talk about mega deaths they measure the deaths by millions of deaths it all just becomes utterly terrifying the scale
以及那种能力——你知道，这些武器不仅会毁灭人类，它们可能会毁灭地球上的每一种生物。但是，泰勒，我的意思是，让我们深入探讨这个问题的核心，嗯，这些东西极其昂贵，也极其可怕，但如果你愿意的话，也许——我的意思是，实际上我可能倾向于这种观点：最终它们拯救了许多生命。许多今天还活着的人，如果这些武器没有被开发出来的话，早就已经死了。因为如果他们依赖常规军械，考虑到我们对人性的了解以及20世纪的历史，双方很可能会打第三次世界大战。
of the weaponry and the ability you know these wouldn't just destroy mankind it would destroy probably every living thing on earth would be destroyed by these weapons but taylor i mean let's get into the the sort of the weeds of the issue um these things are incredibly expensive and incredibly terrifying um but that you could if you wanted to maybe i mean i actually probably would make this case that ultimately they saved a lot of lives that a lot of people who are alive now who would be dead um had these weapons not been developed because had they relied on conventional armaments the chances are given that we know what we know of human nature and of the history of the 20th century that the two sides probably would have fought a third world war.
但我会辩称——现在很多人可能会说这是一个可怕的论点——但我会辩称，拥有如此令人难以置信的恐怖武器遏制了他们的行动，实际上威慑力……对我和平主义者来说，冷战的故事就是一个威慑力发挥作用的故事。现在，我是不是对此完全疯了、过于乐观了，还是你认为其中确实有一些道理？不，不，我认为是有的。我的意思是，这就是威慑的理由。这就是双方的理由：尽管这些武器代价高昂，对经济——尤其是苏联阵营的经济——造成了巨大的消耗，
But I would argue, now a lot of people will probably say this is a horrific argument, but I would argue that the possession of such unbelievably terrifying weapons stayed their hand and that actually deterrence, well, to me, the story of the Cold War is one of deterrence working. Now, am I just being completely mad and over-sanguine about that, or do you think there's some truth in it? No, no, I think there is. I mean, that was the justification for deterrence. That was the justification that neither side, despite the vast cost of these weapons, the huge drain on the economies, particularly of the Soviet bloc,
在西方虽然没那么严重，但对生产这些武器的经济造成了巨大的消耗，尽管有这一切，但它们不会被使用。当然，这触及了冷战意识形态的核心关键。罗伯特·麦克纳马拉（Robert McNamara），也就是60年代初肯尼迪的国防部长，提出了这个概念：毁灭，而某人非常聪明地在前面加上了“相互”这个词。所以这是冷战中最著名的缩写词——MAD（疯狂/相互保证毁灭）。这是一种疯狂的哲学——相互保证毁灭。但你绝对是对的，多米尼克，它确实发挥了作用，你知道的。而且有充分的理由证明它是有效的。因为即使在1983年11月我们刚才谈到的那个夜晚，苏联领导人也没有按下按钮，
less so in the West, but the huge drain on the economy to produce these weapons, despite all of that, that they wouldn't be used. And this, of course, comes to the central crux, in a sense, of Cold War ideology. Robert McNamara, who was Kennedy's defence secretary in the early 60s, comes up with this thing, destruction and somebody rather cleverly adds the word mutual to the beginning of that so this is the most famous acronym of the cold war mad it's a mad philosophy mutual assured destruction but you're absolutely right dominic it it did work you know and there's a there is a case to to be made for the fact that it was effective. Because even on that night in November 1983, that we've just been talking about, the Soviet leaders didn't press the button,
没有发射他们的导弹，因为他们知道这样做等于自取灭亡。所以，顺着这一集的基调——也就是核战争的擦肩而过——我们讨论了1983年，你提到了1962年的古巴导弹危机是另一个我们险些遭遇毁灭的时期。除了这两个例子之外，还有其他哪些时刻让世界险象环生吗？是的，汤姆，绝对有。它们通常围绕着事故、技术故障、计算机失误、这样那样的误解。所以仅举几个例子，1957年7月，在靠近剑桥的拉肯希思皇家空军基地（RAF Lakenheath），一架B-47轰炸机坠毁并滑入了一个存放核武器的掩体。整个事件陷入熊熊大火之中。
didn't launch their missiles, because they knew they would be committing national suicide by doing so. So on the theme of this this episode which is basically nuclear war near misses we've we've talked about 1983 you've cited 1962 the cuban missile crisis as the other time that we came close to destruction were there other particular moments where the world came perilously close aside from those two examples yes tom absolutely they were and they're usually revolving around accidents technical failures computer mishaps misunderstandings of one sort or another so just to give you an idea of a few i mean in july 1957 the rf lakenheath which is near Cambridge, a B-47 bomber crashed and skidded into a bunker containing nuclear weapons. The whole thing was engulfed in flames.
正是由于空军消防队以及当地消防部门极其迅速的行动，才在核武器在这个掩体中被引爆前夕将大火扑灭。1961年1月，一架B-52轰炸机——这种巨大的八引擎喷气式轰炸机之一——在北卡罗来纳州上空解体，可能是由于某种金属疲劳或其他原因。两枚2400万吨级的热核炸弹坠落到北卡罗来纳州的地面上。其中一枚很快就被找到了。另一枚降落在某个沼泽地带，至今未被找到。噢，天哪。它还在那儿。所以一条短吻鳄可能会吃掉它。
And it was only down to the very rapid action of not only the Air Force Fire Brigade, but the local fire brigade that put the fires out just before they ignited the nuclear weapons in this bunker. In January 1961, a B-52 bomber, one of these huge giant eight-engine jet bombers, split apart over North Carolina, probably some sort of metal fatigue or something. And two 24 megaton thermonuclear bombs fell to earth in North Carolina. One was recovered quite quickly. The other landed somewhere in swampy ground and has never been recovered. Oh, my God. It's still there. So an alligator might eat it.
但只要短吻鳄不知道怎么拉响引信就行。在他们发现的那枚炸弹上，六个安全装置中有五个已经失效。1966年1月，最著名的事件可能发生在西班牙的帕洛马雷斯（Palomares）。没错。当时美国人有这样一套系统，他们的基本威慑是通过所谓的“铬合金行动”（Operation Chromedome）运作的。在任何特定时刻，都有12架B-52轰炸机在空中飞行，盘旋在苏联领空周围，就在苏联领空边缘。它们都有预先指派的目标。如果有战争爆发，攻击密令就会发送给这些飞机，它们会立即进入苏联领空攻击预先指派的目标。这就是库布里克（Stanley Kubrick）的电影《奇爱博士》（Dr. Strangelove）中绝妙讽刺的那个行动，其中一切都出了差错，指挥官命令他的飞机发动攻击等等。无论如何，在1996年的这一天——
But as long as the alligator doesn't know how to set off the trigger. On the one they discovered, five out of six safety devices had failed. In January 1966, probably the most famous incident was over palomares in Spain. That's right. So the Americans had this, their basic deterrence worked through what they called Operation Chromedome. At any one moment, 12 B-52 bombers were airborne, circling around Soviet, just on the edge of Soviet airspace. They all had pre-assigned targets. And had there been war, the go codes would have been sent out to these aircraft and they would have immediately entered Soviet airspace to attack their pre-assigned targets. This was the operation that was wonderfully satirized in Stanley Kubrick's Dr. Strangelove, where it all goes wrong and the commander orders his planes to attack and so on. But anyway, on this day in 1996,
有一架B-52从北卡罗来纳州的西摩·约翰逊空军基地（Seymour Johnson Air Force Base）起飞。它执行的是24小时任务。它飞越大西洋，飞下地中海，并在领空之外的苏联西部边境巡逻，但正如我所说，在等待攻击密令的到来。这是一个全天候7x24小时的行动，当天有12架B-52在飞。在执行完这趟漫长的任务后，它正返回美国。在24小时的飞行过程中，它们必须进行两次空中加油操作，而这是回程中的第二次，正准备横渡大西洋，但在地中海上方，这架飞机与派来给它加油的加油机相撞了。天空中出现了一个巨大的火球。绝大多数涉事人员当场身亡。但有四枚热核武器坠落地面，其中三枚降落在帕洛马雷斯附近的一个海滩上，它们很快就被找到了，
there's a B-52 flying out of Seymour Johnson Air Force Base in North Carolina. It's on a 24-hour mission. It's crossed the Atlantic, it's gone down the Mediterranean, and it's patrolling the Western Soviet border outside airspace, but as I say, waiting for the go codes should they come this was a 24 7 operation 12 b-52s on this particular day it's returning to the states after this long mission they have to have two refueling um uh operations in the course of the 24-hour flight and it's the second of the two coming back about to cross the atlantic but over the Mediterranean, where the aircraft collides with the fuel tanker that is sent up to refuel it. A huge fireball in the sky. Most of the people involved are killed immediately. But four thermonuclear weapons fall to the ground, three of them landing on a beach near Palomares, they recovered
尽管它们泄漏了少量的核废料。但第四枚落入地中海花了几个月的时间，而且它非常引人注目地掉进了地中海的一个峡谷里。所以它当时在，我想有2000英尺深，类似这样的深度，花费了几个月的时间才找到这第四枚武器并将其打捞上来。西班牙和美国政府之间关于赔偿金的争论，你知道的，持续了大约50年。事实上，它们是在本世纪初才得到解决的。格陵兰岛上还发生过另一起关于燃料的事故。最终，各国政府反对美国驾驶载有核武器的B-52轰炸机在头顶飞过的做法。这倒也合情合理。他们有着丢炸弹的习惯。至于古巴导弹危机本身，我们刚才已经提到过了，这是冷战中非常非常紧张的时刻，美国人非常害怕苏联人会试图派遣特工进入他们的基地并破坏飞机或导弹。所以在明尼苏达州的德卢斯空军基地（Duluth Air Force Base）的某一个夜晚，
quite quickly, although they'd leaked a small amount of nuclear waste. But it took months that the fourth had fallen into the Mediterranean and it had actually remarkably fallen down a sort of canyon in the Mediterranean. So it was, I think, 2000 feet deep, something deep something like that and it takes months to to find this this this fourth weapon um uh and retrieve it and the arguments between the spanish and the u.s governments over compensation you know go on for for for about 50 years in fact they were resolved in the early part of this century and there's another accident over fuel in Greenland. And eventually governments object to the idea that the Americans are flying B-52 bombers with nuclear weapons overhead. Fair enough. With a habit of dropping them. the Cuban Missile Crisis itself, which we've already referred to, you know, a very, very tense moment in the Cold War, the Americans are very fearful that the Soviets will try and get agents into their bases and to sabotage aircraft or missiles. So on this one particular night at
一名卫兵发现一个入侵者正在翻越栅栏并拉响了警报。这立即触发了中西部其他空军基地的警报。但在其中一个基地，错误的警报响了。那不是“我们有入侵者”，而是“我们正遭到核袭击”。所以所有的飞机都集结到跑道尽头，它们几乎完全武装了核武器，正准备起飞发动报复。直到指挥官意识到错误的警报响了，它们才全部撤回。呼，谢天谢地。
Duluth Air Force Base in Minnesota, a guard spots an intruder climbing over the fence and sets off an alarm. This immediately triggers alarms at other air bases in the Midwest. But at one of them, the wrong alarm goes off. It's not we have an intruder, it's we are coming under nuclear attack. So all the aircraft rally to the end of the runways, they're just about fully armed with nuclear weapons, they're just about to sort of take off to launch a reprisal. When the commander realises that the wrong alarm has gone off and they're all reculed. Phew, thank goodness for that.
回到明尼苏达州的德卢斯，他们发现那个入侵者是一只灰熊。一只饥饿的灰熊差点引发第三次世界大战。但是，泰勒，我想与我早先那种乐观的想法——“哦，它们拯救了许多生命”——形成鲜明对比的是，一些听众会说，这一切的教训是，总有一天，你知道，我们一次又一次、一次又一次地走运，而总有一天我们不会那么走运，地球将被毁灭。
Back at Duluth in Minnesota, they find that the intruder was a grizzly bear. A hungry grizzly bear nearly sets off World War III. But, Taylor, I suppose in complete contrast to my earlier sort of sanguine, oh, they save lots of lives, some listeners will say, well, the lesson of all this is that one day, you know, we've been lucky and lucky and lucky and lucky, and one day we won't be lucky and the planet will be destroyed.
你买账吗？回顾冷战时期，我认为我们是奇迹般地幸运。我认为发生的事件数量——我还可以讲述更多——我们如此接近核事故的边缘，这种事件是由某种误解或某种技术故障引起的。还有很多计算机发生故障的案例。记住，记住20世纪60年代运行核系统的计算机，当然，你知道，其计算能力远低于你今天的iPhone，这些是非常不成熟的控制系统，它们在好几个场合都出了故障。还有另一次是在古巴导弹危机期间，预警系统在进行测试时，把飞过的一颗常规卫星误认为是一次测试运行。同样，情况一直上报到战略空军司令部，要求准备对苏联发动报复。你知道，我认为总体而言，为了回答你的问题，是的，
Do you buy that? Looking back on the Cold War period, I think we were miraculously lucky. I think the number of incidents, and I could relate more, the number of incidents where we came so close to a nuclear accident, coming out of some misunderstanding or some technical failure. There are lots of cases as well where computers malfunction. Remember remember computers that were running the nuclear systems in the 1960s certainly uh you know had far less computing power than your iphone today has these are very unsophisticated controls uh and they go wrong on several occasions and there there's another one in the Cuban Missile Crisis where the early warning system is going through a test and it gets confused as to a conventional satellite coming over and it's test run. And again, it goes right up to the Strategic Air Command to prepare to launch a retaliation against the Soviet Union. You know, I think overall, to answer your question, yes,
我认为我们在冷战中度过而没有发生某种核冲突简直是一个奇迹。每当我的笔记本电脑发生故障或其他什么情况时，它总是让我思考：我们到底是怎么在冷战中生存下来的？但我们确实活下来了。我想进入后冷战时期后，人们普遍能够松一口气了，然而在某种程度上，它可能变得更加危险，因为存在某些闪爆点（flashpoints），可能会爆发核战争，但它不会毁灭整个地球，因此
I think it was a miracle that we got through the Cold War without there being some sort of nuclear configuration. Whenever, you know, my laptop malfunctions or something, it always makes me think, how on earth did we survive the Cold War? But we did. And I suppose going into the the post-cold war period generally people have been able to breathe more easily and yet perhaps in a way it's become more dangerous because there are certain flashpoints where there could be nuclear war but it wouldn't destroy the entire planet and so therefore
也许有些政府会想，嗯，我们不妨试一试。我想这两个臭名昭著的闪爆点是印度、巴基斯坦和朝鲜。这样说公平吗？是的，我认为，结合你提出的这两点，多米尼克，你关于“这是一个平衡的世界，因此是一个更安全的世界”的观点，冷战的双极性质——基本上只有两套权力——确实达到了一定水平的平衡。我们现在进入的是一个多极核世界，几个国家——以色列和伊朗，我把他们也忘了，是的，绝对是的，是的，是的。所以正如你所说，汤姆，印度和巴基斯坦都拥有核武器，很可能会发生争端，
perhaps there are governments that think well we, we might give it a go. And I guess the two notorious flashpoints are India and Pakistan and North Korea. Is that fair? Yes, I think, I mean, picking up on both the points you're making, you know, Dominic, your point about it was a sort of balanced world and therefore a safer world the sort of bipolar nature of the cold war where they were just basically you know two two sets of powers did have a level of balance what we're now into is a multipolar nuclear world where several countries in israel and iran i forgot them as well yeah absolutely yeah yeah so so so both india and pakistan as you say tom have nuclear weapons there could well be a dispute that would
这又会回到我们之前讨论过的关于“神射手”和北约演习的内容——如果一方觉得自己在输，那么它就更可能向另一方发动核打击。所以我们有巴基斯坦和印度。就我们所知，伊朗目前还没有核能力，但以色列有。如果中东发生某种升级的可怕的枪战，那么很难想象那里不会发生核冲突。我们相当确信朝鲜拥有某种核能力，尽管它到底是什么还不清楚。而且，你知道，朝鲜是一个非常不稳定、非常奇怪的政治实体。从某种意义上说，在我们生活的这个多极化博弈中，世界现在是一个更加危险的地方。而且我认为，更容易想象有人会发起他们所认为的有限核交换，并希望能从中获得利益。但任何形式的核交换的问题在于它会升级。那么美国和中国呢？所以人们把台湾称为一个极其危险的闪爆点。你认为有没有可能升级到这样的程度，以至于我们又一次面临核对抗的边缘？正好在播客接近尾声时给听众提提神。
again this sort of what we were talking about earlier with abel archer with the nato exercise you know if one side feels it's losing then it's more likely to launch a nuclear attack upon upon the other so we've got we've got um pakistan and ind. Iran doesn't yet, as far as we know, have a nuclear capability, but Israel does. And if there is some sort of terrible shooting war in the Middle East that escalates, then it's impossible to imagine a nuclear configuration there. North Korea, we're pretty sure, has some sort of nuclear capability, although it's quite unclear what it is. And, you know, that's a very unstable, very strange political entity in North Korea. So in a sense, the world is a more dangerous place now in this
是的，这真是太令人振奋了，不是吗？是的，是的。我的意思是，老实说，我认为这不太可能。我认为中国和美国在其体制内都内置了足够的制约机制。但完全不可能预测。而问题的关键，正如我所说，是这些事情将如何非常迅速地升级。危机和危机时期的麻烦在于，它们会带来误解。它们会带来对正在发生的事情的错误解释。它们会带来恐慌感。这正是1983年发生的事情。苏联人完全误读了迹象，恐慌自己即将遭到攻击。而在我们今天生活的这个多极核世界中，这种情况再次发生是非常可能的。但让我们以稍微轻松一点的基调结束吧。所以1983年，可以说是世界有史以来最接近核战争的一次。
sort of multi-polar game. And it is easier, I think, to imagine that somebody will start what they see as a limited nuclear exchange, hoping to get benefit out of it. But the trouble with any form of nuclear exchange is that it will escalate. And what about the United States and China? So people talk about Taiwan as an incredibly dangerous flashpoint. Do you think there's a prospect that that might escalate to a degree that, you know, we're staring down the barrel of nuclear confrontation again? Just to cheer the listeners up as we come to the end of the podcast. Yeah, this is very cheery, isn't it? Yes, yes. I mean, I think it's unlikely, to be honest. I think both China and the United States have enough restraints built into their systems. But it's entirely impossible to predict. And the trouble,
那次结局算是挺开心的，不是吗？因为罗纳德·里根，他以前满口都是关于“邪恶帝国”的言论，当他通过苏联叛逃者奥列格·戈尔迪耶夫斯基（Oleg Gordievsky）了解到俄罗斯人曾多么惊恐时，他彻底改变了对苏联的看法，（他变得温和多了）——他在回忆录中写到了这是何等重大的启示，他说我从来——他以前从未想过他们会害怕我们。所以从某种意义上说，这算是一个令人高兴的想法。确实是的，确实是的。从某种意义上说，他对这一事件的反应拉开了冷战结束的序幕。他说，我们绝不能再让自己陷入这样一种境地：苏联人
as I say, is how these things would escalate very rapidly. And the trouble with crises and periods of crises is that they bring misunderstandings. They bring a misinterpretation of what's going on. They bring a sense of panic. That's exactly what happened in 1983. The Soviets panicked that they were about to come under attack, having completely misread the signs. And it is very possible that that could happen again today in the multi-polar nuclear world that we're living in. But let's just end on a slightly more cheery note. So the 1983, arguably the closest the world has ever come to nuclear war.
会误解我们，会认为我们可能会发动先发制人的攻击。你知道，美国的观点是“我们不做珍珠港那一套”。你知道，我们不会在万里晴空下出动飞机。你知道，我们不会做这种事。我们必须确保苏联人明白，我们绝不会发动先发制人的攻击。这就是里根在1984年、1985年当关于他们有多惊恐的消息传进来时所说的话。所以他说，我必须去了解这些家伙。然后最终在1985年，在又一个契尔年科——安德罗波夫去世后，契尔年科这个更年迈的苏联领导人上台。当他最终去世时，政治局决定我们必须让新一代掌权。
That did kind of end happily, didn't it? Because Ronald Reagan, who had previously been all about the the sort of evil empire rhetoric when he learned through oleg gordievsky the soviet defector when he learned how frightened the russians had been he completely changed his view of the soviet union and of the you know he became much more he he writes in his memoirs about what a revelation it was he said i'd never it never occurred to him before that they would be frightened of us so that is a kind of cheery thought in a way it is it is and in its way the his reaction to that begins the end of the cold war he says we must never be in a position again where the soviets
当然，这个人——戈尔巴乔夫，米哈伊尔·戈尔巴乔夫登场了。里根向他伸出了手。他们见面了。你猜怎么着？他们相处得很融洽。他们在意识形态问题和战略问题上有着根本的分歧，但作为个人，他们相处得很好。从那一刻起，误解升级为全面核末日的可能性变得越来越小、越来越小、越来越小。
can misunderstand us, where they will think we might launch a preemptive attack. You know, the American view is we don't do Pearl Harbors. You know, we don't launch our planes on our, you know, out of a blue sky. You know, we don't do these things. And we must make sure that the Soviets understand we would never launch a preemptive attack. That's what Reagan says in 1984, 1985, when the news comes through about how panicked they were. So he says, I must get to know these guys. And then eventually in 1985, after another Cheneyenko, Andropov dies, Cheneienko, an even older Soviet leader takes over. When he finally dies, the Politburo decide we've got to get a new generation in charge.
随后是一系列我们都知道的会议、条约和峰会——日内瓦、雷克雅未克、华盛顿等等。这开启了这样一个进程：不仅实现了核裁军，某些中程武器被彻底废除，而且它基本上开启了终结冷战的进程。所以，是的，是的，多米尼克，它确实有一个大团圆结局。
And of course, this man, Gorbachev, Mikhail Gorbachev comes along. Reagan reaches out to him. They meet. And guess what? They get on. They get on well together. They disagree fundamentally over ideological issues and strategic issues, but they get on as individuals. And from that moment onwards, the sort of likelihood of a misunderstanding escalating to a full nuclear Armageddon gets less and less and less.
好吧，泰勒，非常感谢。这太精彩了，虽然极其令人沮丧和揪心，而且——我极力推荐你的书《1983：处于边缘的世界》，这是一部读起来完全令人不寒栗的书，实际上在我读完之后的好长一段时间里都让我夜不能寐。这确实令人不寒而栗，汤姆，但我的意思是——事情并没有发生，你知道的，它可能会变得相当……但它确实没有发生，所以。
And there are a series of conferences and treaties and summits that we all know about Geneva Geneva, Reykjavik, Washington, and so on. And that begins the process, not only of nuclear disarmament, certain intermediate range weapons are abolished altogether, but it sort of basically begins the process that ends the Cold War. So yes, yes, Dominic, it does have a happy ending.
我回想起来，这给我的1983年记忆投下了阴影。
Well, Taylor, thanks so much. That was brilliant, if incredibly depressing and harrowing um and uh i i can't recommend uh your book 1983 the world at the brink enough it's a completely chilling uh read and actually gave me sleepless nights for quite a long time after i'd read it it is chilling though tom but i mean it didn't happen you know it could be quite but it might have happened yeah but it didn't so i I retrospectively cast a shadow over my memories of. Of 1983.
在1980年代的威尔特郡长大。是的。意识到这一点，布鲁克斯书店。实际上，多米尼克，我还要告诉你一件实际上也非常阴暗的事情，那就是我在翻看我父亲的文件时发现的。是的。他有一大堆文件被他保存着，他是风景如画的乔克山谷（Chalk Valley）中布罗德乔克（Broad Chalke）教区委员会的书记员，有一大堆文件是他作为教区委员会书记员被发给的，关于如何应对核打击。哦，是的。
Growing up in 1980s Wiltshire. Yeah. Realising that myself, the Brooks Bookshop. And actually, Dominic, I'll tell you something actually also very sinister that happened was that I was going through my father's papers. Yeah. So he had a whole stash of papers which he kept and he was clerk to the parish council of broad chalk in the picturesque chalk valley and there was a whole load of papers that he'd been given as clerk of the parish council on how to cope with a nuclear strike oh yes and it was all about how to kind of bury dead cattle
内容全是关于如何掩埋死去的牲畜，以及应该在哪里处理尸体。如你所知，所有这些“保护与生存”类的东西我都是超级粉丝，你知道的，当时还有那些公共信息宣传片，教你如何在放射尘避难所外面掩埋亲人的尸体，以及所有诸如此类的东西。我的意思是，我一直认为关键点——我的意思是，我们还没谈到《浩劫》（Threads）之类的东西，我知道泰勒对此很感兴趣，我也是，所有关于核末日的幻想。但关键点，我认为，是要立刻死去。你会希望在刚开始时就被直接焚化。
absolutely and where where bodies should be disposed of and as you know i'm a big fan of all this sort of protect and survive um stuff you know and there was these public information films that told you how to bury the bodies of your loved ones outside your fallout room um and all this sort of stuff i mean the key thing i always think i mean we haven't got onto threads and stuff which i know taylor is interested in as am i all the sort of fantasies of of nuclear apocalypse. But the key thing, I think, would be to die straight away. You want to be incinerated right at the beginning.
你不会想在某种黑暗时代的冰冻废土上游荡。所以我看过的一部电影是一个名叫QED的系列节目，讲的是一枚核导弹投在圣保罗大教堂上，它基本上计算出了会发生什么。我记得他们放了一个，我想是一个甜瓜之类的东西，一个西瓜插在棍子上，然后他们向它炸飞碎玻璃，以模拟身处有玻璃的房间里的效果。那绝对会让我想要当场毙命。
You don't want to be wandering around some sort of Dark Ages frozen wasteland. So one film that I did see was a series called QED, and it was about a nuclear missile being dropped over St. Paul's, and it kind of worked out exactly what would happen. And I remember they put, I think, a kind of melon or something, watermelon on a stick, and then they blew shattered glass at it to simulate what the effect would be of being in a room with glass. And that would make me definitely want to be killed.
是的。因为如果被玻璃击中，你的头部会发生什么？你不会想成为那种生活在末日后的麦西亚（Mercia）王国里与变种人战斗的人。哦，不，《浩劫》的结局——我认为我们应该做一期节目。我们会做的。我们应该就人们如何设想核战争的影响来做一期节目，但也许不是马上，因为老实说，这有点压抑。好吧。带着这种心情。我想我们很快就会回来，希望能聊点更让人高兴的话题。再次谢谢你，泰勒。我们下次见。拜拜。
Yeah. Because what happens to your head in the event of glass hitting it? You don't want to be one of these people who's living in this sort of post-apocalyptic kingdom of Mercia fighting the mutants. Well, no, the end of Threads, which I think we should do an episode on. We will do. We should do that on how people envisaged what the effects
拜拜。感谢收听《历史其余》。想要获取独家播客、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。
of nuclear war would be, but maybe not immediately because, to be honest, it's a bit depressing. All right. On that note. I think we'll be back soon with hopefully some kind of more cheery stuff. Thank you again, Taylor. And we'll see you next time. Bye bye.
核战争会是什么样，但也许不会马上发生，因为说实话，这有点令人沮丧。好吧。带着这个心情。我想我们很快就会回来，希望能讲点更令人高兴的事情。再次谢谢你，泰勒。我们下次再见。再见。
Bye bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。如需获取额外节目、抢先收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集暂时还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。